вас виходячи з потреб. І задач які були поставлені перед командою. Є дійсно необхідність здорового збереження даних так, щоб це було на у спосіб відносно легкий але Промислове Павло володимирович люб'язно погодився, представити як це зробити будь ласка.
Так, я думаю, що перш ніж ми почнемо з тією частиною можливо, тоді, або віталій станіслав можете продемонструвати також для Сергія Олексійовича як клієнта.
Що вже у нас є по вашій частині щоб ми могли оцінити, і тоді якраз перейдемо до основної частина саме таке розробка з запасу там.
Чи можливість зараз продемонструвати екран.
Push.
Photography securing
Класно кажучи, як це вже не як клієнт, але, є така традиційна практика якщо у вас немає реальних фотографій, ви можете використовувати якісь моделі Наприклад, узяти з фотостоків, або узяти силуети людей, і таке інше.
Для того, щоб доповнити а після того, як ви отримаєте необхідний дизайн, змінити навіщо це необхідно чому бажано було б хоча б показати це дає можливість виміряти, перше, наскільки гарно завантажується?
Відповідний сайт, наприклад, через мобільний доступ друге ви можете оцінити яким чином розташоваються у вас елементі так що як то кажуть, заповніть якимись пустичками, не у процесі?
To the district.
Гарна ідея до речі, коли ви користувалися прикладом з бос-страпу там є у відповідному каталозі, зображень були такі модельні стокові зображення що можна було показати це наші клієнти, тощо.
To Micho on the road.
це текст далі. Друге поле Це буде певне число. Не третє поле Це буде категорії типу так ні, одиничка 0 тощо.
що у вас тут структура, досить чітка Давайте спробуємо як це можна було б зробити за допомогою бази даних, якщо повернутися на попередній крок то у вас значить, що я бачу, я бачу, що не є певні, статті, раз так я бачу, що є працевлаштування Тобто, там теж має бути динамічна складова.
Дякую. Так. Павло Володимирович як ви дивитесь на таку Ідею.
Так цілком можемо поглянути ми якраз сьогодні будемо обговорювати баз даних то ми можемо і Ну, ти частину з користувачами або ж монстрами і можливо, навіть можемо поглянути з різними частинами сайту.
Для цього було Б Доцільно щоб відповідні частини були у Репозитарії, до якого мають доступ і Павло Володимирович. Отримати доступ А виконати певне оновлення.
все якщо ми будемо брати наприклад, майстринь, вона дуже часто, йде в комбінації з піч Тобто отримати доступ до бази даних докових налаштувань, буде досить складно.
Бо ж набагато дорожче, в нашому ж випадку, якщо ми хочемо розробити прототиль що ми саме і займаємося на цьому курсі ми можемо використовувати безкоштовні ресурси, такі як банку тобі нам пропонує.
Загалом, Почнемо тоді розглянемо спершу представляємо ангелію та як почати з нею.
Працювати Так. Я тоді А Так. Син.
I used to ballistic escrimo.
Postal. I will.
Так, продовжуючи все ж таки, те, що розповідає Сергій олексійович ми будемо в нашому випадку.
А загалом, чому ми так хочемо використовувати я зараз, ключу демонстрацію?
Так, понто і ми спробуємо розглянути. Загалом, навіщо нам треба базу даних в такому класичному вигляді.
кажемо що в нас є Наприклад, клієнт кого ми позначимо букви к тобто клінія.
Це все ж таки частина з екстремалом це що відкривається в браузері і те, що користувач робить в сучасних реаліях.
сервера. В цьому всьому Звісно, нам ще потрібна база даних. Якщо ми хочемо Звісно, зберігати дані не завжди треба зберігати дані Проте в більшості випадків це є необхідної мови, А однією з варіантів ви можете запустити, сервер баз даних.
На сервері і мати все в одній частині це цілком допустимо, про те, не дуже часто використовуються тому що набагато простіше, якщо у вас є окрема ще базантних тобто це кожен окремий сервер, який спущений і який окремо, працює.
концепти в яких ви можете мати. На велику кількість северів, тут, у нас є мікроавсервісна.
Архітектура, наприклад, в нас Кожен сервер Фактично, має якусь свою функцію.
І такий приклад може використовуватися в будь-якій розробки якщо ми візьмемо наприклад, звичайний сайт, то якщо у вас великий сайт, по типу, наприклад, різного українських великих провайдерів розетки Так, то вам би мало.
Сенс розділити сервери на декілька різних частин, тобто щоб 1 серпня займався.
Купівлею товарів, а інший север загався його готувати щоб вийшло, так, що наприклад, якщо у нас не працюється в аеропорту.
Клієнтська частина ми говоримо про частину на експеррес-жсі та базу даних.
У нас будуть використання Загалом, давайте тоді перейдемо власне, до розробки хто пережить до того, що з собою представляє так з перемикав вікно, так, видно, браусиш як це зроблю трошки можливо, ось так ми будемо використовувати офіційного постачальника.
А монте тобі а загалом я зараз давайте також закрину посилання щоб ви могли під час переглянути так, чат.
Загалом у нас тут є декілька планів. Якщо ви подивитесь в оплату. То у нас є безкоштовний ось Ну, доларів в годину.
Вони нам пропонують досить такі на те, що дуже гарні умови але воно безкоштовно.
вони є відносно дешевими. У порівнянні з іншими провайдерами. Якщо ви хочете звісно, використовувати більші Проте, тільки годину.
Це є досить такі торгов але в нашому випадку нам підходить безкоштовний план, таким вони пропонують під 0 доларів в мене вже є акаунт тому я натисну увійти вакант найпростіший спосіб це використовувати у колакаунтер загалом ми це і використаємо з вами увійдемо в офіційний
те де ваш сервер, запущений і ось у нас тут є всі дані скільки підключень скільки чого відбувається.
Там коли ми створюємо новий сервер у моєму випадку у мене вже є безкоштовний, ви можете лише 1 безкоштовний, север мати ви тут обираєте безкоштовний, і вам потрібно буде лише дати ім'я загалом, я думаю, що я можу зараз спробувати видалити існуючі.
Так.
Можемо видалити і спробувати створити новий якраз заняття щоб було більш зрозуміло.
А поки в нас видаляється Кластер Так. Як ці операції відбуваються в хмарі тому вони можуть не відбуватися одразу бачите, фінанси говорять що 3 які з дії серверів, виконуються що нам перше, треба зробити це все ж таки мати користувача.
Я вже маю якогось користувача, але ми можемо спробувати видалити цього користувача.
І створити нового. Ось нам пишуть що ви хочете створити Проте спробуємо все ж таки перше, створити от ми видалили кластер і ведули користувачі ким в мене був і спробуємо створити з самого початку.
Натискаємо біоткластер і Ось нам пропонують безкоштовний план Ну, як вони говорять що безкоштовно.
Декілька центів. Тут Декілька доларів в місяць. Для вас тому нам Це не дуже важливо ось нам також пропонують оператори регіон Ви бачите тут купа регіонів навіщо нам регіон це Фактично, знайомі з принципом роботи саверів.
То чим ближчий сервер до вашої локації, тим менше у вас буде затримка у підключенні до нам пропонують найближчий це у Стокгольмі.
Ми можемо тут, обрати і париж і Франкфурт і багато інших країн, Але нам пропонують ось такий рекомендований нам не важливо: все Загалом, ми можемо спробувати створити нам звісно, говорять обрати велосипеди але ми спробуємо пройти капчу О Чудово.
От і нам одразу, говорять підключитись до нашого класту.
Перше нам говорить? Що ось вам треба додати вашу Епіадресу до локального до я покажу як це робити, конкретно якщо у вас є динамічна епія адресу то кожен раз, коли будете намагатися підключатись то вам, буде блокувати доступ не хочу щоб ви підключали якихось невідомих епіадрес це
доданий до проекту і далі нам пропонують обрати метод підключення і Тут є декілька в них є вбудовані різні бачите компас.
Це інтерфейс. Можна використовувати консуль кожен кислот навіть віжав у студію за допомогою відповідного Розширення але нам це не потрібно кайбер і тут нам є ось Бачите, декілька варіантів залежності.
Від якого ви плануєте використовувати багато тут їх використовувати багато тут і піч, пі тут вони показують реальний приклад, того, як просто можете скопіювати і використовувати і пайтон але ми використовуємо з вами, експрес- S який побудований на но честь.
Хтось нам говорять що там декілька кроків треба для того, щоб це все, виконати і Ось нам пропонують такий простенький скажемо приклад, ми його зараз можемо скопіювати так 1 момент я вмкнув.
До демонстрацію всього екрану можна було переходити і ми з вами, спробуємо тоді поки що послідовно діяти, по тому що нам говорять так чудово видно, вам зараз відйшов у студію, також.
Якщо можна трохи збільшити.
Так. Ось так. Краще.
Добре, тобто бачите у нас є з минулого заняття, якийсь там наш розроблений сервер?
Дякуємо.
параметри але не дуже, потрібні так і от, власне, таки головна функція, наш Суран А все ж таки підключається до бази даних а конкретно.
До нашого кластеру і далі: ми вказано що ось я хочу підключитись до такої бази, адмін і відправити команду пінк тобто перевірити, чи взагалі, живий той сервер спробуємо запустити його завдання Ну, от і вказуємо наші треба зберегти.
Вказу на шваю і почекаємо чи все ж таки, відбулось. Бачите, у нас спершу підключивши сам сервер А далі?
Напишуть Так. Ми відправили запит до вашого пласту і ви успішно підключилися до до баз даний Чудово.
Тобто, ми ось так легко підключили цей код можна дуже легко спростити можемо прибрати всі коментарі.
Вони нам поки що не треба Ее, фактично Ось бачите, у нас є також файнулі це фактично дуже проста конструкція, яка закриває підключення до бази даних, коли ми там вбиваємо процес ми хочемо також закрити Підключно, до баз даних, не пробував у нас висіти і забирати ресурс
фактично нам це поки що таке підключення, нам майже нічого не дає але перш ніж його змінювати ми повернемося до.
На мангкой типі й Бач минуче все, все, що є Бачите, нам ось говорять що пароль для мого користувача.
Був доданий в рядок підключення лише для першого разу тобто всі останні рази. Вам треба буде запам'ятати його скопіювати десь і зберігати його тому що інакше ви не будете отримувати дозвіл, я зараз можу навіть показати ми натискаємо далі.
присточка Давайте все ж повернемося Ось Бачите, ми можемо перевірити. Що ми підключились до нашої бази даних.
Тобто кількість підключень, збільшилась. І щоб підключитись локально ми можемо використовувати власне, і ось цей сайт так зараз той момент.
Це видалимо пізніше? Щось Користувачі бачите тобто складається від звичайної структури таблиці.
4 ось таких елементів. Айди це є класичним для будь-якого документу авто згенерований теоретично.
Згенерований ідентифікатор ім'я пошта та пароль ну і бачите що паролі ось вони в нас розшифровані тобто ми не можемо зрозуміти що це за пароль навіть якщо ми отримали доступ до бази даних, ми також переглянемо ось цей момент сьогодні як все ж таки не зберігати пароль його чистому
реформ реєстрації нам Тут пропонують різні додатки але нам не потрібні на пускаємо створити чудово бачимо, що нас створилась така структура бачите, Ви не вказували ніякої структури.
Ми будемо не будемо розглядати такий елемент спробуємо все ж таки щось додати сюди перш ніж ми прийдемо до Власне, таке програмного шляху і ось Бачите, у нас можна додати документ.
Чудово ін нам пропонують такий Ось вигляд. Їх тут є 2 або у вигляді що й сонно.
але ви бачите досить такі базові тобто у нас є об'єкти, в нас є інтерж цілі числа.
Чистоючою крапкою а навіть дати булінг або маси в нас є досить обмежена кількість типів про те, нам її вистачить більшість нам потрібно використовувати або стрімко або числові типи ми можемо додати сюди якийсь там?
Естєл-коду просто Перший Тангенс так.
об'єкт і можемо вказувати в ньому. Відповідні дані наприклад, от сказали, де Юзер Нейм-стой у кого нема документу.
Істи але в нас мені здається, повз тест-фюз.
От бачите. Не знайшли Тобто пошук тут також досить простий їх можна порівняти ось цю операцію.
З операцією селект а інша операція власники з нейменною операцією.
Добре. Власне, такий спробуємо тепер працювати з бази даних. Зробити це досить легко. Ми повернемось до нашої бази даних.
І переглянемо що у нас є найпростіший спосіб. Звісно ж, Давайте ми спробуємо з вами створити новий файл, і назвемо його панепшин тут чес ми його будемо просто для підключень.
Нью-йорку, Ми їх скажемо.
І ми не будемо відправляти команду для того, щоб перевірити, що вона там робить і будемо повертати ось цей результат кажемо це буде гарний результат.
Як бачите, всі операції в нас вони використовують та іс для чого це зроблено.
функцію використовувати в іншому пальмі для цього ми можемо використовувати модуль експорт і дорівнює ось такому це є більш старим підходом проте будемо використовувати поки що ж так все фактично, вказує, що ми цю функцію.
Тепер можемо отримати в другому файлі і Тепер спробуємо її все ж таки взяти ось вона в нас по-моєму ми можемо створити якусь спільну баз даних.
сказати приклад.
Конгресу.
Ось такого.
І в нас як бачите, вже є зрозуміло, що це за функція ось ця функція в нас є тут підключення буде відбуватися і ми після цього але як я говорив, це операції а супрун тому нам треба почекати, після неї по-моєму ось тут а бейт і ось він там якийсь консульт у лог ми виведемо з що
донець під 100 та Дивись!
То тоді Давайте спробуємо ми зберегли все і давайте спробуємо ще раз, підключитись і переглянути.
об'єкт ти біль. Ми можемо сказати, тобі і тут, нам треба тепер вказати що саме ви ми хочемо отримати Звідки ми хочемо брати дані щоб.
Ой бачите на підказку вказали Тьот колокшин. І нам треба її вказати ім'я.
І в нашому випадку ім'я було користувач юзеф казали, Чудово, А тепер що нам треба зробити нам треба тепер додати документ.
Для цього можемо використовувати функцію Він сьома бачите, нам також підказала що Ось ми додали Ось так можемо додати ось тут такий.
Ось таку коротку документацію, яку нам зазвичай вказують розробники дає 1 документ в молоко дітей.
Документ документація. Це дуже гарний дізнатись, що Взагалі, функція робить прочитати.
Запускаємо чекаємо поки ми підключимось до президента чудово Повертаючись до нашого читання файлу ось минулого разу там, наш клієнтська частина у нас була і давайте додамо тут, спробуємо якийсь тест і 1 на 3 4 і відправляємо та так бачимо що в нас.
Від полотна яка говорить що так перегляну Клієнт москвинек Дефолт Тобто не говорить, щоб ми не підключились, чомусь яка не те, причина, давайте будемо розглядати все ж таки в чому проблема так?
Ми створили з вами. Клієнти Давайте спробуємо його помістити у функції.
Давайте переглянемо що ж таке у нас є ось тут так ми пробираємо фільтр і просто натискаємо еплан о чудово, бачимо що ми з вами легко додали вже якийсь запис до нашої бази даних тепер я зерней та паспорт із автоматично згенерованим ідентифікатором і це все враховуючи
використовувати Ми Ми хочемо всі Хто отримати це робиться. Просто Нам треба додати.
Сюди осіньки і тут тв тому що ми будемо використовувати підключення до колекцій і отримання не є синхронну о так вказуємо ту ж саму що ми хочемо підключитись до і тут ми можемо отримати дуже схожим до минулих прикладів це те, що ми просто вказуємо ось.
Там Як ми хочемо там?
Ту старий тобто повернутися щоб ось цей масив все ж таки нас перетворився, на чаус-пректорський масив який ми могли використовувати і давайте тепер спробуємо побачити, що ж відбувається.
Ми отримаємо користувачів намагаємося їх відправити назад зберігаємо ні, прогон підключитись повторно чудово повертаємось назад.
Ось нас так ось сюди і нам натискаємо отпільству панель мережі і натиснути отримати користувачів як бачимо ми з вами отримали користувачів з з ідентифікаторами які ми також можемо додати Але це вже і другорядним і поки що не є важливим чудово.
Це досить легко. Саме ось також вказуємо юзерс також підемо Ебейт задоволення.
Чудово Тобто ми шукаємо по всіх користувачах, в яких є такий юзер нейм при реєстрації, далі ми там перевіряємо що якщо користувач.
Довжина Ось цього хід сил більше нуля, то ми не хочемо дозволяти користувачу.
Взагалі щось робити тому ми робимо барикад тому що дуже важливо такі як ер у нас буде виконувати всі операції, послідовно тому якщо ми не вийдемо з цієї позиції, то на жаль, ця розповідь і ми хочемо відправити якийсь наприклад.
Статус першого Кажемо 400 Поганий заклад і далі: відправити ми хочемо якийсь якусь помилку Так, скажу, ера.
Юзер мій пару дітей таке вже ім'я користувача вже не існує і ми хочемо відправити 400 як відповідь що це є помилка, зберігаємо і Давайте спробуємо.
Відправи запустити сервер.
отримати повертає але у нас ось 400 чи поганий запит, і нам Відповідь говорять що журналістів Але якщо ми кажемо тест-1 то такого вже не буде пробую ми бачимо, що ми успішно зареєструвалися нам відправили окей.
Відповідь, Тобто, 200 і тепер якщо ми отримаємо то ми бачимо цього користувача.
Тепер все ж таки важливий. Елемент як нам зашифрувати пароль звісно ви можете використовувати власні розробні штрафування Проте це не є дуже гарним способом.
І, зазвичай тому ми будемо використовувати вже готовий бібліотеку. Досить популярно длянучесу називається вона бійк-кріт загалом можемо їх встановити минулими способами, як ми встановлювали все що було до цього тобто вказано пакетний менше комп'ютер далі.
Тобто ми там вказуємо перспектива зашифрований пароль Але перш ніж використовувати треба додати нам все, ж таки цей бікріт, ось таким таким самим.
Способом тут вказано ось він в нас є читав та і Тепер ми можемо його легко використовувати ось так і в нас тут є вибачте небагато функцій фактично але нам потрібна функція кишування.
додавання випадкових значень в ітерацію і ми бачимо, що з такий ресурс може його використовувати знову ж таки, ця операція є синхрором і то нам треба додавати мейт ми вкаємось наш пароль італії скіль карауд звичайна практика ось Бачите, навіть у прикладах вказують
10 й якийсь там паром. Це зробимо так само вказано пароль і вказуємось тут 10 що треба буде 10, а нагоді хешома чудово.
Таким чином, ми можемо отримати заарештований пароль, і все ж таки, нам його треба тут вказати тому вказуємо пароль і ось хрест, тесне чудово.
страудів. Але все що інше, йде сам пароль вони є в такому вигляді що не можна їх порівняти проте тоді в нас виникає питання, все ж таки як можна отримати як наприклад, увійти користувачі Давайте додамо до нашого ефіру якийсь дуже простенький інтерфейс скопіюємо.
Там то ж так, і додамо сюди, ні, монолотки якому вказуємо користувача, та пароль і вкажемо якусь кнопку також.
Добкін і кажемо будемо вертати якийсь Статус також ось тут ми можемо його вказ кажемо тут айдi також так нам треба змінити буде всіх логін п'юцернень було він паспорт.
Москва. Моїх ось так і тут скажемо якийсь також будови привітний статус вказувати чи взагалі ми можемо увійти в акаунт.
Чи не можна І тут будемо повернемось тоді то те, з чого скрип у нас тут є купа методів.
І будемо.
Скоро функція нового для фото.
Нашу на наш сайт треба використовувати дуже схожу до Ось нашого сенс структуру.
І тут просто пишемо у лоту чому так і ось так і ми тут створимо з нами й пустять блокін то чудосту кінця будемо відправляти ось ці дані туди все просто інванчу складно так далі нам також створено користувачів сюди.
І нам треба ось тут у вакцин чи то ми можемо тепер бути але нам треба все ж таки написати у логі частина з дизайн у нас вже готова.
Ось як бачите але ну день поки ще нічого не робити тому що в нас немає такої точки.
Чудово. Тоді Спробуємо її. Створити. Повернемось до нашої сайту.
І ми хочемо ще одну створити ось таку пост, такпост.
Точку доступу і впевнено що це буде там було все ж запити від відповідь чудово. Ми теж хочемо отримати.
Пароль та користувача з тіла запити і що нам треба з ними робити? По-перше, ми хочемо спробувати знайди такого користувача як ми зараз вже робили.
Досі тільки от в нашому випадку, нам треба ось ми хочемо знайти його в і отримати перш ніж вказуючи.
для гарного стилю зробимо ще перевірку користувачів довжина, якщо та вона більше одного то ми там хочемо повернути статус 400 що там якась у нас критична помилка.
це той, кого ми хочемо Тобто це не якась кара який просто хоче увійти за це ми перевіряємо парон для того, щоб перевірити пароль, ми будемо використовувати функцію.
Тому. Ми тут, можемо вказати а що ось такий астан у спецслужб, чи є пароль про правильним це також синхронна операція вона буде використовувати бікріпт аа її нам треба ось бачити компир тобто порівняй а і ось нас тут є приклади як це робиться тут у нас є звичайний пароль, який ми
відправляємо і ще якісь там пароль у двох прикладах про строки ось так вони використовують функцію першу вони вказують аргумент пароль а далі вказують хеш дітей зробимо першими, покажемо пароль, який ми отримали а далі нам треба з користувачів, дістати ось той пароль, який є
зафіксованим і далі. Ми перевіряємо що якщо там все ж таки нам це повернуло тру А воно повертає бачите, ось нам говорить ресурс тру якщо вони однакові.
Якщо ж вони не однакові. І пароль, якийсь інший то нам повернуть фос чи пароль не є коректним.
Ось, ми в такому випадку хочемо там, повернути якийсь статус там, 200, наприклад, і відправити що там, там.
То ж молодь що ми там пішли в систему, окупованих територій. Ми не хочемо дозволяти користуватися.
Нічого робити Ну, в нас неправильний парад 2 вказані відповісти там наприклад, 500 якась помилка, сенс взагалі можна і чотирист правите також там статус.
Ні модей неправді дамiксь і Тут також може повернути статус.
Чудово. Давайте тоді спробуємо це запустити.
Ще раз. І так підключилось до бази даних і у нас тут так спробуємо такі використати нашу Перевіримо ще раз все тут коректно так все чудово!
Можемо ще раз. Спробувати перевірити?
Так добре, тоді спробуємо отримати доступ до якогось користувача от у нас був тест за 3.
Так, нам ще треба отримати доступ буде до даних, які він повертає Тобто для цього буде використовувати схожу структуру до того, що ми мали в тобто, син реч ну, може й сон, нього далі пиш фанс, відповідь і ось тут документ, отримати його за які і наступчить
Полот Статус.
тей Тобто бачите ми отримали 400 як підтвердження того, пароль не є однаковим і це з урахуванням того, що навіть якщо переглянув.
які будуть генеруватися після того, як користувач йшов щоб наприклад, ми не могли бути на сайті, вічно.
Та лише якийсь період проте ця тематика досить складна для нашого проєкту і в нас та й немає потреби для цього взагалі а так я бачу ми якраз по часу.
Сергійовичу що ми робимо? Тоді?
О власне Павло Володимирович давайте спробуємо враховуючи те, що ми трошки перервалися через повітря.
Тривогу, можливо, дещо розширити на кілька хвилю Гадаю, що найперше, питання, яке турбує вони використовують динамічні айпіадреси коли з власних комп'ютерів, спробувати зробити щоб айпі-адреса у них була певним чином зафіксована.
Так, вам ще нагадали ми пропустили Ось повернемось до нашої і ось у нас тут.
Є в юриті захисті у нас тут є доступ до баз даних натхнення ось і нам говорять що ось таких альпіатрас ви можете мати доступ ми можемо цього епі адресу прибрати також спробуймо її видати так вони тут і Давайте тепер спробуємо підключитись заново до бази даних.
Не маючи ніякого як перейти адресу, доданої і от нам бачите, навіть говорять ваша данте, адреси не додана до точки, добре, ми спробуємо підключитись.
ваших кластерів немає окремого якогось налаштування яке б дозволяло нам для кожної бази даних, свій там окремий доступ.
Дякую. Тобто, власне у навчальних цілях. Ми можемо дозволити доступ усіх адрес і нібито позбавитися відповідної проблеми Водночас, наразі колеги нам демонстрували що вони використовують Ses на їх комп'ютерах.
Так.
У той час як програмне забезпечення, врешті-решт, має бути розгорнута на певному сервері системи, серверів 1 з яких підтримує Отже, ви з цього приводу нам рекомендували.
Нам досить легко. Підключатись до нашого точніше завантажувати наш сервер і далі.
працювати незалежно завантажити існуючого нашого наш серверну частину і підпишітись до бази даних, тобто, отримати вже готовий сайт, на який зможуть зайти інші користувачі.
сховище виключно для елементів тощо. У Такий спосіб дійсно Ваше програмне забезпечення буде працювати можливо, в ньому буде обмежена функціональність не завантажиться картинки не буде можливості додавання тощо.
Буде Це суттєво. Краще, ніж всі яйця як то кажуть скласти в одну корзину і коли сервер, недоступний у нас все є недоступним, Дякую.
Павло Володимирович Шановні колеги, ймовірно, у вас є запитання, які стосуються сьогоднішнього матеріалу запрошуємо будь ласка.
Ну поки складно, щось сказати ну чи все нормально.
Ну, це Так.
Добре.
обставини можу а не тому, що не хочу проте, ми з палом. Володимировичем. Обов'язково принаймні пізно ввечері. Обговорюємо ваш прогрес і подальша робота так що зустрінемося.
Дякуємо Перепрошуємо за затримку і Бажаємо щоб ваші вихідні пройшли без Ось таких подразників що тут, були здоров'я наснаги, і до зустрічі на все, добре.
До побачення.